At oncologists today, my I don't know if this person means C-E-A or what they're
meeting their C-A something and their C-A-15 I think they made the C-A-15-3 triple
these are two remarkers tripled in six weeks any suggestions yes we should have
a conversation we should do another cheek swab we should at least have a
conversation next week but you see your tumor markers you know go up a few
points or go down a few points you shouldn't really get too excited it's just one
marker and that can change just things are going but if it triples then that's
a concern now what is it not a concern if the tumor marker goes jumps really high
it's not a concern if the person is doing chemo therapy so if the person is doing
chemo therapy that can cause ISIS and that could cause a person's tumor
markers if you're doing tumor marker tests doesn't always but it can cause the
tumor marker system triple or quadruple or go up ten times so if the person who
asked this question is doing chemotherapy then I don't set up a time to talk to me
but if not then we should talk we should probably talk after you get your
bone scan and CT results back I'm still having kidney pain since COVID is
that sure which way to turn let's wait till we get your bone scan your CT scan
so we have more objective data to go at and and be able to answer that question